We can solve this for instance by distinguishing between three different cases.
First case, time is between 0 and 4 years, the output is 0.
Second case, the time is 6 years or greater. The output will be 0.8, the maximum sustainable yield.
Third case, we need a function to describe this line if the time is between 4 years and 6 years.
The slope of this line is 0.8 times the maximum sustainable yield
divided by this time span 6 years minus 4 years.
The slope is multiplied by t, but if we're just using this expression, this would be the result that we get.
A line would intercept zero.
The trick is to subtract 4 years from that time, which would make it work.
We still have this expression still describes the line with the right slope, but if you plug in 4  years,
this coefficient times 0 and thus the result is 0 for 4 years.
In the resulting diagram, you see how the growth of the population
softly bends down between 4 and 6 years,but we are not over fishing.
The implementation makes use of a factor to modify the maximum harvest rate
which is 0.8 times the maximum sustainable yield.
If the time is larger than 6 years, we are using the factor of 1.
If the time is not larger than 6 ix years but it's larger than 4 years, we're using the linear ramp,
and otherwise, we are using the factor of 0.